[Music]
caitlyn is with us in minnesota hi
caitlin what's up in your world
hi dave um it's an honor to talk to you
um
i
i uh
so me and my husband have been married
for about four years and um sorry i'm
like really nervous it's okay we've
never lost a patient you'll be okay
um and
we operate by what i call the roommate
method
um it's where
you know we have a mortgage payment i
give him my half he pays the bill right
and
i know we want to do the dave ramsey we
want to do all your baby steps he's
already our thousand dollar emergency
fund
but he wants to take care of his debt
and he wants me to take care of my debt
and i've tried to talk to him and i
don't know
what to say what to do how to and we've
been through like the money and marriage
seminar last year we've done financial
peace university together
everything
i know i know
all of it
make you repeat the second grade here
it hurts my heart a lot because i love
him and i know that if we can get
through this
you know and get through
our p to get through this
that things will be great i just i don't
know if i'm not saying the right thing
how old is he
he is um we're both 28. okay i thought
you married a child for a second i just
want to get the ages right before we dug
in you guys please stop saying that
about him
i'm sure he's a great husband what it
feels like
these are my toys and these are your
toys and i'll play with my toys and you
play with your toys but when you guys
said i do
it was we from then on out there's no
roommate method there's no it's husband
and wife yeah and that means joint
accounts that means conversation
communication combining everything and
it's now our debt yeah but he's you're
saying he's not in there too
it's and i don't totally blame him
well
he hasn't given me an excuse he just
whines
no he doesn't whine yeah he is you don't
talk about it a lot yeah but um his wife
is calling me on national radio after
you've been through financial peace
university and been to the thing so yeah
that's called why not yeah no really
this is this is this is bad
so um
okay so what you've got to do with him
is you're gonna have to get to the
bottom of what his problem is what's his
objection
why does he why does he not want to
combine after four years why do we not
why are we not french we we
it's we yeah when you're married it's we
not yours and mine we're not splitting
the mayonnaise the bologna and the other
stuff in the refrigerator that's my
mustard keep your hands off of it we're
not roommates yeah
yeah
and it's not good for your marriage and
it's not good for your wealth building
it's not good for your relationships
it's not good for your level of
communication there's nothing here
that's good so why is he insistent upon
doing things that are not good i'm
confused you are too
so maybe he needs to maybe he needs to
defend himself on that
yeah well and i kind of
i've been the free spirit i've never
been good at handling my money but i
want us to do it together so we can
learn together you know
yeah i mean if you two laid out a plan
that both of you agreed to called a
monthly budget
would you stick to it if you had a vote
on the plan
oh gosh yeah
well then the free spirit is not the
problem yeah but free spirits not the
problem because even a free spirit can
stick to a plan
yeah if they have a vote and a voice in
the plan now he doesn't get to lay out
the plan and then make you do it that's
not what we're talking about no and he
wouldn't because we've tried before and
i i don't know what happened
to be honest
but we've tried before
do you guys have a why that you've laid
out when you talk or does he just not
want to talk does he just shut down
no we've talked we've done the whole
dreaming thing we want you know to
be build wealth we both want to change
change a leg change generate like our
generation
you know we want to have a good legacy
like you know uh it's are you sure it's
a good legacy for him i knew you were a
good legacy
are you sure it's not just you
we've talked we have talked about it
before
and he has said it i think he carries a
lot of shame with having so much
like because coming into the
relationship it was his debt
and i have debt too yeah but like you
said we get married it's ours but he's
better for worse shameful for richer for
poorer
unto thee
all my worldly goods
yeah i pledge
for better for worse
for richer for poorer
unto thee
all my worldly goods i pledge
this is a relationship
issue
it's affecting your money
and i'm getting to the bottom of it if
i'm here this is not okay
[Music]